[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the upcoming harry potter tv
show and cast reunion soon to be
released on hbo in a trailer recently
released by the wizarding world fans
were met with the news that hbo are
going to be hosting an hbo max special
in celebration of 20 years of harry
potter the special will feature a
massive cast reunion and notably the
reunion of the trio daniel radcliffe
emma watson and rupert grint other
actors from the beloved franchise
expected to join will include helena
bonham carter robbie coltrane ray finds
jason isaacs gary oldman imelda staunton
tom felton james phelps oliver phelps
mark williams bonnie wright alfred enoch
matthew lewis ivana lynch and ian hart
and for all you muggles that's bellatrix
hagrid voldemort lucius sirius umbridge
draco fred george arthur ginny dean
neville luna and quirrell harry potter
20th anniversary return to hogwarts will
premiere on hbo max on new year's day
january 1st 2022 the feature will tell
an enchanting making of story through
all new in-depth interviews and cast
conversations the official trailer has
amassed over 14 million views on the hbo
youtube channel to date so i think it's
fair to say that there's some excitement
regarding the upcoming show the show
will be released on january 1st but in
the meantime we can obsess over a
screenshot from the show that was
recently released in this screenshot we
can see the famous trio hermione granger
harry potter and ron weasley aka emma
watson daniel radcliffe and rupert grint
all sitting together for the first time
in ages and in the gryffindor common
room of all places are you ready for
this magical first person journey
through harry potter history
comment down below we're just a few
weeks away until next time remember we
do not need magic to change the world we
carry all the power we need inside
ourselves already we have the power to
imagine better